end-of-the-year traditional list making
time so we're pretty much done with 2017
and that means obligatory wrap-up top
ten movies that I saw they came out this
year I'm contractually obligated as
somebody who talks about movies on a
youtube channel to go through these
motions so I saw I think it was twenty
eight movies altogether that came out
this year so I was pretty busy keeping
up with stuff and some of the movies
that are on this list are not movies I
did individual reviews for either
because they weren't movies that I
thought my audience had an inherent
interest in or in some cases I saw them
you know far enough after they had been
in theaters that I felt like it wasn't
topical at anymore now before I get into
the list I also want to say if you want
to stick around towards the end I do
have kind of a bit of announcement for
something that's coming up in the not so
distant future so stick around for that
if you're at all interested or curious
or did I did I piqued your interest your
curiosity or do you not care in any case
why don't we get started
coming in at number 10 Blade Runner
20:49 the placement of this one on the
list might be confusing to people who
saw my review of that which was a very
conflicted one and I still kind of am
conflicted about this film overall but I
cannot deny that it is incredibly well
made and it does a very good job of
accomplishing what it sets out to do
some of the differences that are
inherent with the story that it's
telling and how that differ
differentiates it from the original
Blade Runner causes a specific aspect
that I really love about that original
film to be lost but that is really
specific to me and and looking at the
year overall I still really think this
is a really well-made movie and I think
it still deserves the number 10 spot
number 9 war for the Planet of the Apes
I honestly thought this was gonna be
higher before I went and saw it but I
unreflecting I think is probably my
least favorite of the new Apes films
it's still really good though Andy
Serkis as Caesar is phenomenal the just
the whole direction that the story has
gone Woody Harrelson is always good he
makes a fantastic villain in this
and it does really hit a good emotional
core with a lot of the character so even
though I consider it my least favorite
of this revised trilogy of eight films I
still think this is a really fun movie
number eight and one that I suspect some
people are gonna tune out right now that
because I'm not putting it higher than
this Logan and again I like Logan I like
Logan very very much but also realize
that this ranking has to do with my own
personal taste and preferences this is
not an objective measure Logan is by
most objective measures a better film
than a lot of the ones that are going to
be above it but as good as it is and as
good as it is at doing what it does it's
just not the kind of movie that at this
point in my life I am just seeking out
as much then the kind of nihilism like
the world is is a mess like I get enough
of that in my life to a certain extent
that I don't gravitate towards that kind
of movie as much as I do but I still
recognize the skill with which this was
made it is an excellent film and anyone
who has it way higher on their top 10 or
even their number-one I'm not gonna
argue with you it was a terrific swan
song for Hugh Jackman and also Patrick
Stewart as Charles Xavier it is a really
well-made film number 7 cocoa movies
with family feels have a tendency to hit
me pretty hard and this delivers that
really well not the best necessarily in
terms of Pixar or even some of the other
animated films of the last few years but
still does really well in terms of its
family dynamics and just the the
conflict in the contrast with all that
and the importance of family and the
importance of remembering the people who
we love and who we may have lost that
really does it it hits you and it's
touching and that counts for a lot and
this was a movie that I really enjoyed
seeing that I was touched by it's
visually really wonderful the
realization of the land of the dead is
just absolute visual feast it is
wonderful to behold and it's gotten some
really terrific character working some
very touching arcs on top of that number
sick
thor ragnarok boy yeah you know I
enjoyed the first Thor film I think more
than a lot of people did but I think in
many ways up until this point the Thor
individual films have been on the lower
end of Marvel's individual franchises
Iron Man could go up and down but Thor
hadn't gotten as high as I the cap that
America films have been phenomenal then
the Thor films have just kind of been
there and then this thing comes
thundering in with a whole new sense of
identity and a whole new feel and yet at
least for me didn't feel like it was
untrue to that character in that world
it still felt correct even as it it
brought in more of a guardians of the
galaxy Sensibility
I think Thor really worked in that world
I think the way Hulk was used was really
good I liked the villain I loved the
Valkyrie there's there's really not much
that I didn't like here except for some
wine nitpicky stuff but you can see my
review for that and that isn't a lot of
way what Held's it back the stuff that
again I will admit our nitpicks bugged
me enough that I can't boost it higher
than this place but boy this was a ton
of fun
number 5 guardians of the galaxy vol 2
this is a film that I enjoyed when I saw
it and and I said at the time it's good
I just don't like it quite as much as
the original I don't that's still the
case now they're really neck-and-neck
and I have a hard time making that call
because this is a movie that I've seen
several times more since it came out and
the more I see it the more I like it it
is a shift it is less plot driven and it
is more emotional driven it is about the
emotional damage and depths and journeys
of these characters in a way that the
more I saw and the more I kind of
drilled into a when that's some really
smart insightful stuff huh and I sort of
became more forgiving of just the fact
that it had not the same sort of caper
rob kind of feel to it that it felt a
little bit different and it didn't feel
as new but it really is
a wonderful emotional dive into these
characters who we've already gotten to
know and love in the first film so I
liked it when I first saw I've liked it
even more when I've seen it since so
that's what puts it as high as it is and
like I said at this point I'm not sure I
could tell you whether I like original
guardians or this better
they're both great number for Wonder
Woman Wonder Woman does have its faults
I talked about them in my review and the
fact that those are false hasn't changed
however the things that I love about
this movie I love so much that they do
actually help bring it up because it's a
weird thing with me sometimes sometimes
it's easier for me to forgive a sizeable
misstep that I understand why it
happened as opposed to a nitpicky
misstep that I'm like I don't understand
why that even happened yeah I mean to
make the comparison with some of the
things that held the ragnerok back for
me
so with Wonder Woman the third act is
it's too much fire and noise the villain
I you know doesn't completely work he
works on a thematic level but in terms
of a rewarding confrontation doesn't
quite work but dal Godot is so good in
this part I mean she is spot-on perfect
casting she nails it the stuff that the
mascara is great it is awesome I like
Chris Pine as Steve Trevor
his exit is beautiful there's a ton of
just tiny little moments that are in the
film that just give it so much and make
it more than what it could have been
which it could have been really
disposable but it's not just little
moments it's also big moments that no
man's land sequence is probably my
single favorite isolated scene that I
saw this year at the movies and you know
what that goes pretty far in my book now
before I get into my top three I need to
do an honorable and some dishonorable
mentions the honorable mention it would
be really quick now this is - a movie
that actually came out last year but I
didn't see until this year so it was it
on my list last year if I had seen it
before the end of 2016
trust me it would have been on that list
and it would have had a good shot at
number one and that is the hand
not handmaidens tail the handmaiden it
is a Korean film that I don't even
really how to describe this it goes back
and forth in terms of genre and focus
and who's the hero and who's the villain
and what is going on so masterfully it
juggles so many tones and feels and
genres that it did should there is no
way that this should work but it does
and it's awesome and if you didn't see
it you should
so my dishonorable mentions normally I
would have what I thought was the worst
movie of the year I'm actually not gonna
do that this year because most of the
movies that I saw that were the most
objectively bad our movies that I don't
care about they're you know I there it's
a situation where it doesn't really
bother me that it was so bad it annoys
me that I had to sit through it but you
know it would be stuff like boss baby or
Despicable Me 3 or even you know stuff
that actually does matter to me that it
wasn't very good like Batman and Harley
Quinn or Teen Titans Judas contract even
that like it doesn't work me up enough
that I feel like designating it worst
movie I saw this year so I'm not gonna
do a worst movie of the year however to
make up for that the other dishonorable
mention that I usually do goes to the
most disappointing movie of the year and
I've got a tie for that one a couple of
movies that are on the list for very
similar reasons which is going to be
Kingsman the Golden Circle and Star Wars
the last Jedi and when I say they're on
here for similar reasons in both cases I
came out of the theater initially
disappointed and in both cases the more
that I thought about them the less that
I liked them and also in both cases the
directions that they went based off of
where the films were previously it just
makes so many missteps in terms of where
you go based off where things were left
off last time that I just don't
understand how this happened
I've got individual reviews for both of
them and I don't want to rehash them
right now because I want to get back to
the good stuff and keep things positive
so having gotten through that let's get
back to number three
spider-man homecoming I didn't know how
much I was gonna like this I just
to be decent because we haven't had a
good spider-man movie a long time I
really love this movie and this was
another one I've seen this one twice and
I'd like to diva more the second time I
saw it the all the changes that have
been made to spider-man as a character
and his mythos and his relationship with
the people around him are just
intelligent decisions and I'm not saying
that like the changes they made are
better than the original version but
every change that I see I go the reason
to do it this way as opposed to another
way is a intelligent reason that was a
change made with purpose not just
because and as a result I just really
love this taken it helps that Tom
Holland is wonderfully charming he has
terrific chemistry basically anybody
he's sharing the screen with Tony Stark
is used sparingly but smartly Michael
Keaton is a wonderful villain the kind
of villain that I have wanted in a
spider-man movie for a while now and we
just haven't gotten in many ways he was
one I wanted Sandman in spider-man 3 to
be and that just I don't want to talk
about that movie it's just a really
wonderful return it makes me so excited
to see future Adventures of this version
of spider-man number 2 another one that
I saw more than once and another one
that the more I saw it the more I liked
it
the Lego Batman movie I'm not kidding I
love this movie so so much it is first
of all it's hilarious it is and it's so
chuck a block full of Easter eggs do all
things Batman who is very obviously as
much of these as it is picking on Batman
as a character because the thrust of the
plot is that Batman needs to get over
himself and as much as it is picking on
the over seriousness of the character it
is very obviously written by people who
love this character and who have deep
knowledge of this character and his
world and that is evident from every
single moment and the fact that it's
also the Lego version just that adds a
lot of little fun goofy moments to it as
well in terms of how the thing gets
resolved at the end and then just some
of the the weird things like with the
Robin
costume and how that works all the stuff
it's so good but you know what even
beyond that I think if you strip every
joke out of this it is still a perfectly
serviceable good even Batman story even
if it wasn't also being hilarious at
every step and that to me is the key of
any good comedy is it still a story
worth telling
if you remove every single joke and in
this case I think it is I think it's a
solid Batman story and then you'll a
really good really fast-paced really
clever humor on top of that and again a
surprisingly potent emotional note at
the heart of it really delving into
Batman and this whole idea of he won't
let himself get close to people because
he can't bear the loss again it's
surprisingly deep for something called
the Lego Batman movie this came really
close to getting the number one spot it
doesn't though and the number one spot
goes to a movie that I actually haven't
talked about on this channel and this
was a movie I saw pretty early in the
year and pretty much every time I came
out of a movie that I liked after seeing
this I came out going that was good
wasn't quite as good as that one though
and that honor my pick for the best
movie of 2017 or at least to me get out
the seamlessness with which Jordan Peele
goes from biting satirical comedy to
allegorical horror is so masterful to be
to the point of it's it's almost
shocking to think he ever did anything
other than a horror his ability to not
only present a situation and
circumstances that are horrifying in and
of themselves but to give it context and
depth and symbolism and meaning that
just this is another one I've seen
multiple times the more times I see it
the more like oh my god he like went
through this thing with a fine-tooth
comb everything means something and it
is so smartly written so well done it is
a masterful examination of race
relations I mean that is what the thing
is about but it
is done really really smartly and it's
not bashing any particular it's not it
tackles racism but not in the
low-hanging fruit way because generally
if you're gonna try and tackle a big
issue in horror you tend to go for the
low hanging fruit the more typical
horror movie would have had the the race
aspect be like he goes to meet his
girlfriend's parents and they've got
like a friggin Confederate flag up or he
finds a clans mask in the closet no eCos
simpler Co subtler goes more insidious
and it rings all the truer because of it
get out is a fantastic horror movie
completely on its own merits and but
then as an allegorical commentary on the
state of society and race relations it
is a friggin masterpiece so those are my
picks for the ten best movies of 2017
now I said I had something coming up at
the end so 2017 has been kind of a
bonkers year for me I started this year
with 1,200 subscribers and I am going to
be I don't even know where I'm gonna
land by the by the time this thing is
over I'm recording this a little bit in
advance so that I can kind of relax so
as we get to the holiday stretch but I'm
gonna be around 9,000 by the time the
year is over that is insane I am more
than septuple to my subscriber base in
one year and for how long I've been
doing this that's nuts that thing's
ramped up that quickly and are
continuing to so I've got a couple of
milestones coming up as a result of that
I'm coming very close to 500 300 and
10,000 subscribers don't know which of
those two I'll hit first but I want to
kind of mark the occasion and I thought
the fun way to do that would to be would
be to do a QA so I'm taking your
questions whether it's about the channel
about me about whatever you know my
whatever you want to ask me you can drop
it here in the comments you can send it
to me in an email council of geeks at
gmail you can hit me up on Twitter at
Council of geeks however you want to
send your question in do it and I might
answer it I make no promises as to how
many of these I'll answer the
how many I get what they are and and
I'll deal with that when when the time
comes but to mark 10,000 subscribers and
or 500 videos whatever happens first ya
gonna do a QA so send me the questions
I'll answer them cuz I do want to mark
the occasion I do want to celebrate
because this has been in terms of this
channel and the growth of it has been
amazing and I'm really grateful and
thankful and I hope everybody has a
really fantastic 2018 so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]